oh please I think we're on the wrong
level sorry before engine Marga Blair
box escape box you have to eject your
stupid son to win Pressey to see the
sun's camera okay
did I win Oh kid you better win
oh come on oh I died for you
I hope you understand that oh well then
our survival you will never make it
looser haha kill him oh yeah well I hope
that was because you okay then it went
up through my bum hole my bum hole and
straight to my blame can you
sassafrassin let me live can you sisal
Frissell let me live
can you bliss all fall under dumb curve
Lumbee dumb habu be doobie am balls okay
son now let go it's time for a father to
move on I'm gonna win in this level what
the hell happened here oh my god it's a
spike fall why am i fear
okay what is it still twirling around oh
nothing okay bye world why am I being
held up by markiplier hardcore alright
then
was I supposed to not survive that I
seem to have some foreign object
sticking out of a bum I think that's my
leg
whoa my dad
Margaret jump whoa whoa whoa whoa space
them down okay got it okay this one's
made by Casper I can tell and then oh
hey boy what are you doing here boy
Boogedy boo that's how he talks I think
I'm pretty sure anyway I don't know I'm
not a professional Irishman guys so hard
and so this levels so big it's so hard
Oh God so the innuendos to make cover
will you Tim
Oh boggle our turbo dismount
even the wheel selects right okay then
they're not really dying much they just
kind of falling over like little itty
bitty rag dolls that's so adorable I'm
not exactly in the chicken car anymore
but my god
that's awesome markiplier Apollo 13 by
rat Kobe oh my god no oh my god it's a
girl there's actually like space it's
actually like space give me the coins
give me those delays it coins oh my god
this is amazing
holy crap hi mr. coin do I need all the
court I'm gonna lose my voice all over
again I was just slightly okay there I
go god damn it how where'd I go I broke
the game okay I just gotta go about this
very very carefully because if I if I
don't I'll spaz out and launch into a
different dimension
hi again foxy don't worry about me I'm
fine I can do this game all by myself
holy crap this is amazing oh did I die
am i dead okay space mines meteors I
don't know I'm not dead yet oh my god oh
this this is so cool
don't kill me don't kill me it's gonna
kill me don't why is it stuck in my ship
don't blow me up don't blow me up don't
blow me up don't blow me up okay it's
it's my god that was incredible
highlights thanks for watching if you
want to see more happy wheels right now
check the description or click the
annotation for the full happy wheels
playlist and if you want to see more
happy wheels in the future please click
the like button to let me know thanks to
get everyone and as always I will see
in the next video by